hello everyone i'm alana vlogging my
channel uh i if you didn't already know
i'm a very big pokemon fan that's what
charlanazad means it's my name in the
middle of charizard there was a pokemon
presents presentation this morning
about 12 hours ago now we're watching
this on the gamespot youtube channel i
have not seen any of it i've had no
spoilers i'm not expecting this to be
anything huge but i'm excited regardless
because they got new stuff on the way
that i've already been excited about so
we're just gonna hit play we're gonna
watch it it's gonna be a good time
hopefully
[Music]
thank you
i've been here my whole life my whole
damn life
thank you so much thank you mr brown
thanks for the sub youtube i'm streaming
this on twitch just so you're aware if
you're watching this on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i think this looks so good also this
game for some reason volume is way
louder than everything else
[Music]
ah
[Music]
right in the nostalgia you know what i'm
saying
my god
[Music]
oh my
okay
[Music]
this looks so bad when they seem
cool
[Music]
hell yeah
i'm here for it mikko's [ __ ] pokemon
dance [ __ ]
i mean sorry this is child friendly
dancing is a fun activity to do with
friends
[Music]
yeah she just makes me
dwarf fortress
cool
[Music]
dude it looks very good
[Music]
i would like more
giant tax please yes more sicker
[Music]
and they come with dubstep
[Music]
time speaks
oh god
i'm being assaulted by text
they make strange trailers that's what
i'm gonna say
i am
definitely
down
november 19.
brilliant time to chinese [ __ ] stupid
ads gamestop game spot i mean
i know that it's on me
taking the september 14th
but also
i'm going to go with diamond personally
the release of pokemon brilliant diamond
and pokemon shining pearl is now just
three months away
yay let's review the main points of
these revitalized games i mean they i
really like the way they look
i like the side style in general for
pokemon years it's less nostalgic of
course they could have just remade it
you know have been reborn to how it
looks from pokemon shining pearl
this adventure takes place in the sinnoh
region
and rich in nature what the heck
as the protagonist you'll adventure
across the region catching wild pokemon
and making new friends as you strive to
complete your pokedex those pokeballs
really do look cute pokemon you'll
overcome the gym leaders of each area
and aim to become sometimes you just you
just gotta use geodude to slap some
girls about your traces of the sinnoh
region's myths pass down through the
generations and unravel the truth behind
their mysteries
this is professor rowan who entrusts you
with a pokemon he's a famous professor
yeah i like to tell people who lives not
just slap grass instead of uh
touching grass friend and rival he hones
his skills as a pokemon trainer through
your friendly right
mark is one of the gym leaders you'll
take on during your journey he uses rock
type pokemon
everywhere you look team galactic is up
to something i don't know who's doing
their haircuts
but i think they should issue a
statement
a formal apology
cynthia is investigating myths about
pokemon she's a mysterious person who
shows up at many points along your
journey does she like it's like like
when i'm in bed like oh no cynthia don't
show up while i'm in the shower features
from pokemon diamond and
this is very cool and i like it a lot so
places down there called pokemon
hideaways which didn't exist in pokemon
diamond and that is correct apparently
the pokemon that appear in the pokemon
hideaways will change depending on which
statues you have placed in your secret
base it seems that some of the pokemon
living in the sinnoh region can only be
found in this place
so be sure to fully explore the grand
underground spread out beneath the
surface i'm glad that they've made some
some changes like that you can use those
fractions you'll collect on your
adventure to customize the effects that
appear when pokemon spring out of
pokeballs such as confetti or fireworks
by collecting stickers at various
locations along your journey and
decorating with them you can make your
pokemon i don't know who's doing this
but you also what is that sticker on
okay symmetry that was not available in
pokemon diamond and pokemon pearl is the
ability to change your outfit
where are your favorite styles on your
adventure that meant something different
back in my day
[Music]
i'm excited about the outfits though too
i like that a lot i changed the music
closed pretty frequently in pokemon go
test move and aim for a successful they
have interesting styles cooperate with
your partner pokemon to really work up
the crowd
in the union room this release allows
you to use not only local communication
but also online communication to
interact with trainers all over the
world in real time
please enjoy battles and pokemon trades
with many other trainers
you can walk around with any of the
pokemon that appear in these games
enjoy your journey that is fun together
with your partner pokemon
i'm a fan of that feature also since
since back get out of here award winning
good behavior and the mystery get out of
here um
since pokemon yellow which was the first
one that i ever played
we hope you look forward to starting an
exciting adventure with new gameplay
features you know what
i am excited
i can't accidentally sink way too much
time into pokemon
it can be problematic for me
but i think that i'm gonna be just fine
this time just a bit longer for the
start of your adventure
but that's not all these presentations
are very weird switch light dialga and
pal edition will also be released to
celebrate the launch of these games
this special nintendo switch light is
dressed up with art of the legendary
pokemon dialga and palkio now i need to
mine the special nintendo ds lite onyx
edition that was released back in 2006.
oh no i'm a huge fan oh no it will be
available to purchase beginning november
5th 2025. i regret hearing any of this
next no information for you about the
pokemon legends arceus game which is
being developed by game freak
i'm very interested go on sir
what information do you have
other than the cynical is cyndaquil
going to give me the information
take that as a no
problem
all right nerds i'm not trying to fight
you i'm just trying to get information
like the gentleman why did they even
have that in there
this is a tale of a time long ago when
the lives of humans and pokemon was
still separate
this game
i really hope it's good man i just
really hope it's good
[Music]
i've wanted this game
for such a long time
[Music]
i've always i've always said that god of
war is the one pokemon that i'd [ __ ]
[Music]
the fact that i said that no so
nonchalantly i caught myself off guard
but i have always said that
she's got it going on that's what i'm
saying
[Music]
it looks so cool
it does still look like a ps3 game
though
you really you know could have maybe
done some [ __ ] off state farm
i just i got a lot of [ __ ] for this um
from pokemon fans you know because
there's a difference between me a
pokemon fan who named myself after a
pokemon and has pokemon tattoos and like
loves pokemon and like
pokemon fans and they got very upset
with me when i said that i bought the
pokemon snap graphics looked bad but i'm
gonna say it again these graphics are
terrible it doesn't matter if you
compare it to other games in the pokemon
franchise and go but it looks good
compared to this it looks really
bad
it's so sharp and pixelated that's all
i'm saying
[Music]
that's a growler
what what did they do to you bud what
have they done to you
oh my
i like the pokeballs though
[Music]
if it's like zelda means pokemon you
know like not zelda like specifically
breath of the wild which is what it
looks like
[Music]
that's sick that's all so sick
[Music]
i've just wanted this pokemon game for
such a long time except it should be a
ponyta because that's what i dripped
about as a little girl
[Music]
that's a very angry gyarados he's very
grumpy
oh i wonder
[Music]
gyarados is actually my favorite pokemon
that's not gyarados genuinely
um everybody thinks it's charizard
it's not
[Music]
did that ball just thought
sometimes i put fireworks too
[Music]
what if we don't think his hair
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] nosepass you big donkey looking
thing
oh
i would like the video game
even if i wish it didn't look like it
came out in the year 1995.
[Music]
yeah dude
yes dude
that was the latest trailer for pokemon
legends arceus
i want it let's take a closer look at
some of the elements introduced in the
video i would love to
pokemon legends arceus is a brand new
title that opens new doors for the
pokemon series by fusing action with rpg
elements good yes
your adventure takes place in a region
it does look silly
very pretty era when it was rare for
people to live in harmony alongside
pokemon
mount coronet towers over the center of
the land with sprawling diverse natural
environments surrounding the mountain on
all sides
these different areas are home to a rich
variety of pokemon ecosystems
in the future this land
will come to be known as the cinema the
townsville you'll set out on an
adventure with the goal of completing
the first ever pokedex probably not very
regen
[Music]
the bustling jubilee i agree with them
i agree with them they just said i don't
care if the graphics look bad i'll still
play it because it has the features i
want from an open pokemon game i agree
i'm going to play it the division but i
am still going to complain about the
graphics of the security core and
generally i don't even care i just feel
like it's distracting
in this case professor lavinton's field
of study is the beauty of pokemon he
came to the hisui region along with
pokemon he met in various other regions
he entrusts one of these pokemon to you
captain silence
[Music]
he's a dependable leader who has earned
the unwavering trust of his team members
when the commander recognizes your knack
for pokemon research he allows you to
join the team and has you work as a
member of the survey corps
survey outings the beauty of the survey
corps is just what i've always wanted
pokemon to shed light on how they live
your survey duties hold the key to
unlocking the true purpose of your
adventure and in the course of your work
you'll visit various locations within
the history so nice
your excursions outside the village will
begin by preparing at a base camp at
these camps you'll be able to prepare
for your survey work by buying items or
crafting new ones from basic materials
cool cool cool cool i'm into this in the
his region you'll find i got two heavy
balls attacks from wild pokemon take too
much damage from their attacks and
you'll black out so pokemon just beating
up humans in the street now they work
when your pokemon are hurt you can
return to a base camp to rest up and
recover
once you've completed a survey
assignment return to the village is the
survey assignment drawing pokeballs of
pokemon as well could we not have
approached that differently i'm sorry i
make fun of things that i love
pokemon live all over the place
get close to them and aim carefully then
throw a pokeball to try to catch them
you'll find that not all species of
pokemon react the same way when they
spot you for example some pokemon will
immediately flee there are friendly
species tall grass when you approach
them
aggressive pokemon on the other hand may
need to be weakened in battle there are
cool
catching them all
[Music]
throw a pokeball containing one of your
own pokemon near a wild pokemon and a
battle will begin
you'll find that a scenic
you can also choose to have pokemon use
their moves in two different styles
strong style and agile style
using a move in a strong style will
increase the move's power but the
pokemon's action speed will be lowered
using a move in the agile style will
decrease the moves power but the
pokemon's action speed will be raised
you'll find the strong style will come
in handy when you see a chance to end a
battle with one powerful move while the
agile style is great for situations
where acting multiple times in a row
will give your battle strategy a real
boost use these different styles as the
situation demands to gain the upper hand
in battle i was like super interested in
this why who's placing these ads
damn you game spot
not to be fair they're allowed to make
money i support them i take back all of
my anger i'm just mildly inconvenienced
it's fine
okay
when you report the results of your
survey work to the professor information
will be can i get his hat somewhere you
can advance your research is anybody
selling more information by doing things
like cool hacks
seeing them use certain moves multiple
times and more look at it seek out and
meet lots of different pokemon to
complete that he looks like
a sort of a purple strawberry sort of
we'd
this pokemon with distinctive antlers is
known as weirder weirder evolves from a
stantler that has managed to live in the
harsh natural environment of the hisou
region
it has strong ties with the local people
and it has been treated with great care
and respect in this land since ancient
times garments made with the first shed
from its beard tail and legs are highly
prized it really does have a sick beard
but that do not look frizzy legion very
respectable great power
masculine that live in the his region
can evolve into this pokemon if they
become possessed by the restless souls
of other masculine in their school that
have perished during their journey
upstream it's a pretty tale you got
there gains power from the souls
possessing it letting it swim on and on
without tiring there are also pokemon
that can be found living in this land
and forms that have adapted to the
environment of the hisoo region oh
that's why he looks like a [ __ ] that's
why you do
you did growl with daddy because he
evolved to the region until he got bangs
with psychic power to generate shock
[Laughter]
i hate it
uses it only when it'll have the
greatest effect
[Laughter]
and he's got a gavel hidden somewhere in
all that [ __ ] hair she wears this wig
now
my
[Laughter]
he's going through a face he's just
exploring himself you know
son of a [ __ ] those were our latest
updates on these new entries in the
pokemon series thank you
okay pre-orders
a lot of weird pauses again brilliant
diamonds somebody needs to tell pokemon
company they don't have to available on
nintendo wait for someone onto this
broadcast
i'm
very excited about it announced that
support for these titles is planned to
come to pokemon and i assume that means
there'll be more regions of legends as
well
pokemon
announcements for further details i will
i will you you do have to catch them all
i realized not that long ago so many of
you continue to enjoy the pokemon
pokemon sword and pokemon really from an
early age got us hard into capitalism
an even more competitive play in the
future will not take place in pokemon
interesting
those are all the latest updates thanks
man
we hope you're looking forward to all
the exciting pokemon adventures to come
i am
thank you all for tuning in and watching
the fact that pokemon gets you from a
really early age got me from i don't
know whenever it came out
to to want to collect absolutely
everything i just feel like it's worth
acknowledging that it has still had that
effect on me today
i am
27
i've been playing pokemon or
experiencing pokemon for the better part
of my life
and
i still am like i must consume all of
the news and get all of it and i feel
like that comes from from the jump as a
kid than being like hey
you gotta catch em all they put it they
put it in right in in and we all just
you know it's in the marketing slogan
and we all just thought that that was
just a happy little slogan and here we
are
i am still trying to get them all the
messaging
worked but really i do love pokemon i
really always have um
definitely prefer the latter half of
this presentation but it is about what i
expected stoked to see more of legends
i'm very much looking forward to that
game even if i think the graphics look a
little bit but um but for those watching
me on youtube i'm not going anywhere
twitch you don't worry about that i'm
staying
thank you for joining me i'll see you
guys next time